The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GUEST SPEAKER: Good morning.
Today we're going to
start with a demo,
and we're going to
show experimentally
some of the principles
we've learned
about 4F systems in
the past classes,
and actually we're going to see
a comparison of an incoherent
versus a coherent 4F system
when imaging resolution target.
So but since now we have
all the tools to understand,
finally, the set up here,
let me just describe it.
I've been showing some
of these components
over and over the
past demos, but I
guess now we can
understand it, so
let me try to focus the camera.
So let me start with
this is a green laser.
So the first component
that we have here
is [? anti ?] filter
that its job--
thank you-- so this
component, its job
is to control the
intensity of light
so we can attenuate it in
this case for experiment.
This is an interesting component
called a spatial filter
that is composed of a microscope
objective and a pinhole,
and now that we know what
Fourier transforms are,
the microscope
objective is essentially
taking the Fourier transform
of the laser beam, which
ideally is a plane wave, so
it should be a delta function.
However, since this plane
wave is not perfect,
it has high frequency noise.
So then the pinhole,
what it does
is it does a low-pass
spatial filtering.
So it basically removes all
these high frequency signal,
and after these we have a nice
spherical wave coming out.
This component here
is an iris, control
the diameter of
this spherical wave,
and this element here
is my collimating lens
that will transform this
spherical wave into a plane
wave.
In this case, this is
just a beam splitter
that will allow me to
couple from this side, where
I have a white light source.
In this white light source,
we have a green filter,
so then we only have
green light coming out.
We have an iris again
to control the diameter.
Right now I'm blocking
it, so it is a beam block.
And these are collimating lens.
So here it should be
the planar equivalent
of the incoherent side.
This is the planar equivalent
of the coherent side.
This mirror here bends the
light 90 degrees to send it
to the side from here.
This is the one line
of the incoherent line,
and then should go
into the common path
of the coherent line.
Then they basically
bend again 90 degrees,
and this is the
4F system section.
So here we have first an
element, which is the object
that we want to image.
The object is called
the resolution target,
and it's a clear substrate,
so a piece of glass
that has patterned chrome lines
of smaller and smaller sizes
that we're going to see.
Then we have our first
lens of the 4F system.
This is a non-magnifying
4F system,
so these two lenses are
exactly the same focal length.
So first lens.
Then this is an aperture
in the Fourier plane
because we're going to start
with low-pass filtering.
The second lens, and
then we're imaging this
into our detector, which
uses CCD seamless array.
So now we're going to
switch to the camera
and start with a coherent case.
So the first case, it's like
what we've seen in class.
We're going to illuminate this
object with an inline plane
wave.
OK, let me just zoom
in a little bit.
So this is the
resolution target,
and it's in imaging
condition, right?
So the object is in the front
focal plane of the first lens,
and the detector is in the back
focal plane of the second lens.
So what you can see
here is we are actually
imaging all the way to
groups two and three.
This resolution target
has lines even larger,
which are one and two
that we don't see here.
And the first thing we
see is the following.
We see some fringes,
which are produced
by the interference
from the glass,
so it's basically the reflection
of the plane waves interfering
with each other.
So this is very typical
in coherent imaging.
We see other rings that are
produced by dust particles
maybe along the way.
So all these fringes right now
look destructive to the image,
and perhaps they are for
certain applications.
However, for those of you
doing digital holography,
you notice that these fringes
contain a lot of information
that is encoded about the
amplitude and the phase
of the signal that
we can exploit.
So just for
comparison, I'm going
to zoom in and see what is the
maximum that we can see here.
So you can see that we can have
a resolution now that we know
what the optimal resolution.
With good accuracy
we see maybe down
to this side of the
group number five.
All right, so in the
homework we learned
about the low-pass
filtering in Fourier domain.
So just to remind
you, essentially
what we're going to do
is that the first lens
is taking the Fourier
transform, and it
happens in the Fourier plane.
So then in that plane
we put an aperture,
centered, and then
what we do is we're
going to start reducing the
diameter of the aperture
to try to low-pass filter
the signal more and more.
So what do we
expect to see here?
Well, you did it
in the p-set, so we
expect to see some blurring,
progressive blurring.
So I'm going to do
it, and hopefully you
can see it from there.
So right now it's all open,
and I'm going to blur it.
So I'm going to do it again.
This is clear.
Blurry.
So I'm controlling
with this iris.
And you can see how the signal
that contains the higher
spatial frequency in
this area goes first,
then this one and this one.
But all of them now--
in this blurry condition,
if I try to zoom back again,
now we see how the
signal is really blurry.
If I open the aperture,
it becomes clear again.
So now let's do the comparison
of the exact same thing.
What would you think it would
happen if I switch illumination
now to incoherent light?
So I'm going to block the
coherent light here, and then
the first thing that we
notice is that we don't have
those fringes anymore, right?
So it looks like a
very clean image.
So again, in this case,
you can think about
that for microscopy,
this is very nice.
However, from the digital
holographic point of view,
we don't have that
extra information
that we can use in
encoding of the signal.
Now let me zoom in to compare
the resolution in this case.
So you can see it's
hard to tell if we don't
do a quantitative study to see
exactly what is the smallest
line that we can
see in each case,
but we can see the
comparison again
versus the resolution in the
coherent and incoherent cases.
And now let's do the
low-pass filtering.
So again, this aperture
right now is fully open,
and then I started closing it.
And I'm closing and
closing and closing it.
Open again.
Close it.
So we see two things.
Remember that the incoherent
system is basically regulated
by the OTF, as opposed to the
ATF in the coherent system.
So now that you
can think of it--
the easy terms is it's a
[? combo ?] because the OTF is
a normalized cross
correlation of the ATF, which
means that when I
close this aperture,
you can see how the
signal becomes weaker
and weaker because essentially
I'm restricting the DC
component that happens to
be in all the signal there,
but also gets blurry.
It's hard to see, but
it's getting blurry.
It is getting blurry
at a different rate
as the other system.
So now let's go to
high-pass filter,
and I'm going to switch
back to the coherent case.
So this is the coherent case.
So right now what
I'm going to do
is that I'm going to remove the
aperture in the Fourier plane,
and I just did a very improvised
high-pass filter, which
basically is a microscope slide
that has a little piece of tape
in the center just to block the
basic component, or kind of,
but anyways, it works.
Somewhere around here--
let me crank up the light.
And we can see how basically
we remove the DC term.
And you see the high-pass
filtering effect,
which is essentially
accentuating
all the edges of the signal.
Now I'm going to put
the incoherent case
and the coherent superimposed
just to show edge detection.
So this is a normal thing.
We can accentuate the edges.
So what is interesting
also here is
that if you move the
filter in different places,
you can, say, just
accentuate the edges
in the horizontal direction or
in the vertical direction, et
cetera, et cetera.
We see that the
incoherent case, we
don't see the same effect,
which is as expected.
Again, it's a normalized
cross correlation.
But with a coherent case, we
do see these drastic change.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Thank you.
Any questions about the demo or
about coherence, incoherence?
AUDIENCE: How do you
tell whether something's
partially incoherent or
completely incoherent?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
OK, so the test
is with one of these
interferometers
that Se Baek showed last time.
You basically measure
the fringe contrast.
For example, if you're worried
about spatial coherence,
you set up a [INAUDIBLE]
interferometer [INAUDIBLE],,
and the fringe
visibility will tell you
the degree of coherence.
If it is full contrast,
it is fully coherent.
And of course, you
never see full contrast.
You never see-- it's always
somewhere in between.
OK, so today we'll
have a flashback
of geometrical optics.
I will go back to something
we saw in geometrical optics,
and that's the single
lens imaging system.
Oh, and before I
forget, on Wednesday,
it is the project presentation
for the graduate version
of the class, so I
wanted to remind you.
I will also send an
email from the website,
but if you haven't
done so already,
you should have a meeting
with your project mentors,
finalize your
presentations, and then
on Wednesday, what we'll do is
it'll be a conference style.
Each group will have about
15 minutes, approximately 12
for the presentation,
approximately 3 for questions.
How many groups?
I think we have six
or seven groups.
So typically, these
things run over,
so we'll take
probably the full two
hours with the presentations.
So for those of you in the
2.71, you don't have to attend,
but I think it would be very
useful if you do because it's
sort of interesting.
It is more advanced material.
The graduate students
will present some topics
from current
literature, and you'll
get an idea not only over the
basic optics that we'll do here
but also what kind of things
happen in the research front.
For example, last
week several of us--
Pat, Yuan, and Sean--
were at the conference
in Vancouver,
so some of the topics that
were represented on Wednesday
were actually big items
in the conference.
The conference was
actually called Advances
in Imaging, this spring
congress of the optical society.
Anyway.
So going back to
the lecture, this
is something that
we've seen before,
but with geometrical optics.
Now we try to understand
how the same system works
but with the wave optics.
And if I could have the
tablet again, please.
So the way we analyze the
system, of course, is we'll
basically have to propagate
using Fresnel diffraction
to propagate the field from
one element to the next
until we reach the
end of the system.
So for example, at the input
we have the input field.
I will write it
in one [INAUDIBLE]
so we don't write too much.
The input field is
simply the product
of the illumination field times
the complex transmittivity
of the input transparency.
I will do everything
for a spatially coherent
illumination, and we know now
that if the illumination is
spatially incoherent,
if we have already
solved the coherent
case, we're in good shape
because we can simply take the
modular square of the point
spread function and
the autocorrelation
of the coherent amplitude
transfer function,
and then we can compute the
correspondent quantities
for the incoherent case.
So the coherent is the one
that we'll always start with.
OK, so doing that now, we
can calculate, for example,
the field immediately
to the left of the lens.
So let's call it g
sub L minus for left,
and I think I still use x
double prime as my coordinate.
So this is now a Fresnel
propagated version
of the input field, so we'll
write out the big, bad Fresnel
integral.
e the i 2 pi z1 over
lambda i lambda z1.
So this is the
[? prequel, ?] and then we
write our big
integral here, g sub
in of x, and then the quadratic.
And of course, two things
happen at the lens plane.
First of all is the lens itself.
That will impose an additional
quadratic phase delay
upon the signal, but
now it's a little bit
different than the
geometrical optics case.
I forgot to mention
earlier that I
have added a thin transparency
in front of the lens.
So this is again a pupil mask.
As we will see in
a moment, it does
pretty much the same
job as the pupil mask
did at the Fourier plane of the
4F system, but in this case,
we actually put it sort of
in contact with the lens.
In fact, we don't have to.
We can put the mask
anywhere we like,
but anyway, it makes the math
a bit simpler in this case.
And in most implementations,
for practical reasons,
they also do it this way
because it is much better
to have everything
stacked together,
as opposed to having
different elements
sort of floating around
in an optical system.
OK, so this means then that
the field to the right hand
side of the lens, so the
plus now means to the right,
still x double
prime coordinates,
is going to equal to
the field that was
on the left multiplied by 2.
Two functions now.
One is the thin
transparency itself,
which I denote
there as g sub pm.
pm, of course, stands
for pupil mask,
like in the previous cases.
And then times another
complex quadratic
exponential that corresponds
to the lens itself.
So this would be e
to the minus i pi x
double prime square
upon lambda f,
where f is the focal
length of the lens.
And finally, the
field at the output.
Now the output
coordinate is x prime.
It's going to equal
another Fresnel propagation
from the pupil mask
to the output plain,
so I have to write another
propagation term here.
This would be z2 this time.
And what I will put now is gL
plus because this is the field
to the right of the right of
the composite lens and the pupil
mask, so that would be
x double prime and then
another quadratic exponential.
OK, so this is it, and when
you plug in all this math--
this is something
we've done already,
so I will not do it
in the class again,
but there is a supplement.
There is a scan of
my handwritten notes
in the website where you will
see a little bit more detail
on how I did the
derivation here,
but I will skip some
of the immediate steps,
and I will show the result here.
So the way you handle this
kind of-- as you imagine,
when you combine all
of these integrals,
you will get a sort of
integral that involves all
of these functions, g sub
in, g sub pm and so on,
but also you will have a bunch
of quadratic exponentials.
So what you do is you
expand the exponents
of these exponentials,
and you rearrange terms,
and you write it out this way.
So these are the
output coordinates.
They don't participate
in the integration,
so we can knock them
out of the integral.
And then of course, we cannot
do much about this thing
because, well, we don't know
what these functions are yet,
but we can certainly try
to see what we can do with
the remainder.
So what is sort of glaring
here is that in the exponent,
you have quadratic terms, and
you also have linear terms.
The linear terms, we
know from experience
that they lead into Fourier
transform, so they're nice.
We'll know what to do with them.
The quadratic
terms, they usually
correspond to nasty things like
the focus, but in this case,
you can see that the
quadratic term is multiplied
by a coefficient
here, which allows
us to knock it out if
we select the distance
as z1 and z2 judiciously,
and of course that
is the result of the lens law.
This is the same
equation that we
derived using
geometrical optics,
and we'll call it the
imaging condition.
So you can see here that when
you satisfied this imaging
condition, then you essentially
knock out the focus term
from the diffraction integral.
So that is gratifying
because we actually
derived a result from
geometrical optics,
but this time it is perhaps
more rigorous because it
is based on electromagnetics.
What is the rest now?
Well, we'll deal with
the rest in a moment,
but you see that there's another
quadratic here that we cannot
quite so easily get rid of,
and this extra quadratic that
popped up there is interesting
because it is not predicted
by geometrical optics.
So this is something that--
well, it will happen only
with spatially coherent
illumination, and geometrical
optics cannot predict it
and actually cannot
deal with it.
And in fact, not so
long ago, about the time
I was born in the
early '70s, this
was a topic of research,
what to do about this term.
In fact, Professor Goodman,
who wrote your textbook, one
of his early results
as a young scientist,
he wrote the famous
paper about this term,
what this term means.
And he wrote it--
I believe he wrote it in 1971,
exactly the year I was born.
I'm not that old, so I
guess that you can still
call it a relatively
recent development.
So again, we're talking
about this term over here,
what to do about this one.
And then of course, there's
an entire section in Goodman
that talks about this
term, and I would encourage
you to read the section.
I will show a summary here.
Something got messed up that
with my animations here.
This was not supposed
to be here, but anyway.
So Goodman actually
goes over three methods
that you can use to eliminate
this unwanted quadratic.
One of them is you lay out the
input transparency as a sphere,
or in a spherical
surface, instead
of the typical planar surface.
That may sound a
little bit strange,
and it's probably very difficult
to implement in practice,
but conceptually
you can see what's
going on because now these
points in the transparency
start with an
original phase delay,
you can work out the
curvature right here.
In fact, the
curvature would have
to be exactly z1, the
areas of curvature,
so that it cancels this
unwanted quadratic.
So that's one way.
The second way is
to actually stick
a lens in front of
the transparency.
This is actually very often done
in geometrical optics as well.
This is called the
condenser lens.
So for example, we
don't have this anymore,
but actually, we do have
one in the classroom.
We used to use these projectors.
Basically, if you look at the
top surface of this projector--
I don't know if I can
take it out here--
but if you look at it,
it's actually a lens.
After class, come over and look.
There is grooves on
it, and basically,
sort of the grooves implement
equivalent of a lens surface.
If you do the operation modulo
2 pi on the surface of the lens,
instead of having this
surface that we typically
think of as a lens, if you
do a modulo 2 pi operation,
you will get something
like this, of course.
OK, so that's a way
to make a thin lens.
That is called a condenser.
The reason we put
it in a projector
is not to eliminate
this quadratic factor,
it is simply because it makes
the illumination uniform.
So when you project
the slide on--
I don't know if
you guys are maybe
too young to have
ever seen anything
like this in operation, but
the next time if I remember,
I'll bring an old
fashioned transparency,
and I will show you
how people of my age
used to give talks
at conferences
when we didn't have PowerPoint.
But anyway, this is done
actually very commonly,
to stick a lens in front of--
just attached to a thin object.
But there are some cases
you cannot do that.
For example, in
the microscope, it
is very difficult
to imagine sticking
a lens behind the glass slide.
So in some cases,
this is applicable,
and in some it is not.
Anyway, a big application
of this type of lens
is of course in
overhead projectors.
Does anybody know
another application
where people use
this kind of lenses,
or what might motivate you
to make this kind of lens?
Can you think?
These lenses are commonly used--
actually, you know?
AUDIENCE: Do they
sometimes stick them
on the backs of vans or
cars to make it wide angle?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right, yeah.
That's another application.
Exactly, to improve the
rear view of the driver.
And that's a good one.
I wasn't thinking of that.
Yet another one is in very
high power illuminators,
which are most commonly used in
photography in shooting movies
because the glass, as you know,
is not a very good conductor,
so it would hit up very
badly if you illuminate
with very high power.
They're called,
actually, babies,
these really big
light bulbs that they
use when they shoot movies.
So they actually use these.
It is called a Fresnel
lens, the same Fresnel
lens in Fresnel propagation.
So they use the Fresnel lenses
in these so-called babies.
All right.
And lighthouses also, yeah.
So again, every time that
you have a really huge light
source.
Of course, it's a matter of
practicality also, right?
If you have a major
lens, as you can imagine,
if the diameter is big,
then also this size
would also be very big, right?
So in a lighthouse,
you might have
a lens that is maybe 1
or 2 meters in diameter,
then it would have to bulge
over another half meter or so.
That's not very practical.
It is heavy, fragile,
blah blah blah.
So they make the Fresnel lenses
to get around this problem.
A good thing to
remember about those
is that they generally give
very poor image quality.
So if you try to use
this as an imaging lens,
you typically get a very bad
blur and a very bad image
quality, but obviously in the
lighthouse you don't care.
In an illuminator,
you don't care.
And also the projector, it is
not used as an imaging lens.
The imaging lens is a
real lens, this one.
This is simply collimating
the illumination
so you get a uniform
image at the image plane.
So for jobs like this
one where you basically
want to take a light bulb
that is highly un-uniform.
It has filaments,
all kinds of crap.
So this is a very
nonuniform field.
This type of lens is
very good to uniformize
the intensity,
and then of course
if you need to image
a sharp object,
then you need the real lens.
You cannot get around that.
OK, that's a bit
about Fresnel lenses.
So that's a bit
of a detour, but I
wanted to point out
some practical ways
that you might be able
to do this kind of thing
if you need to get
rid of the lens.
And finally, what John Goodman
proved back when he was young
is that there's a
condition that you can
neglect this nasty quadratic.
Again, we're talking
about the quadratic
that you see at the
top of the slide.
So it turns out if the
field of the object--
when we say the field,
sometimes in geometrical optics
we mean the size of this.
So if the field is smaller
than about a quarter
of the imaging lens,
then it turns out again
that the effects of this
term are negligible,
and therefore we can get rid
of it in clear conscience.
So I will not go
into the details.
There is discussion
in the book and also
reference 303 from
the book is an article
that Goodman wrote
back then, and he
goes into this in a
little bit more detail.
It's a pretty
interesting article.
I'm going to leave a post
on the website if you like.
It's pretty interesting to read.
So assuming then that will get
rid of this extra quadratic--
let me go back one.
So we got rid of one
quadratic from the lens law,
and I spent a lot of time
arguing about this quadratic,
that maybe you can
get rid of that
then as well, assuming you
can get rid of that as well.
Well, anyway, even
if we don't get rid
of that, what is left in here
is actually Fourier transform.
I think I pointed
that out before.
A Fourier transform-- why?
Because you have
linear now, linear
exponents times
some coefficient,
and then here you
have the pupil mask.
So again you recognize
something familiar.
The same thing happened in
the case of the 4F system.
We again got a
term like this one,
but it was slightly different.
Instead of z1 z2 in
the denominators here,
it had f1 and f2, the
two focal lengths.
Here we have the two distances,
but it's pretty much the same,
and again the pupil mask
appeared in the kernel here.
So this is a Fourier
transform, and of course we
get rid of this term, and let
me jump through these animations
now.
OK, so if we're doing that,
then what we finally get
is this expression
here, where, again, this
is the Fourier transform
of the pupil mask.
I wrote it in a form that
looks a bit more like a Fourier
transform, and of course u and
v are now arbitrary arguments.
These are the spatial
frequencies in the Fourier
transform, but what
actually goes in there
is these parameters over here.
So basically we get again a term
that looks like a convolution.
So we see that the image,
the complex optical field
at the image is a convolution of
the input field times something
that again we will call
the point spread function.
And this point spread
function, just as
in the case of the 4F system,
again here the point spread
function is given as the
Fourier transform over
the pupil of the
pupil mask scaled
with appropriate coordinates.
OK, and there is various
scaling forms and factors here.
For example, this one again
ensures energy conservation,
which is kind of
important, but very often
in optics we don't care so much
about the absolute intensities,
which means that we don't
really care about this term.
What we really care about is
about the spatial distribution,
like the type we're solving,
whether features make it
to the image or they get
lost due to spatial filtering
and so on and so forth.
So very often these
multiplicative constants,
we just drop them.
That's sort of convention.
Now, to get a little
more insight out of this,
imagine for a moment that
the point spread function
becomes extremely narrow.
It becomes a delta function.
So if you substitute
the delta function
into the expression
we had before,
then you get this
expression, which
is of course again
very gratifying
because now the output
really looks like,
again, some multiplicative
term, but then it really looks
like the input,
except in the input
now, the coordinates
have been scaled,
so therefore you can immediately
see that this term is
the magnification.
In fact, the lateral
magnification of the system
is given by this expression.
So we basically
rederived the same result
that we got from
geometrical optics--
namely, the lens law that
is the imaging condition,
the magnification and
so on and so forth.
Now we've got them back from
our wave optics approach,
but we had to do
some approximations.
For example, we had to
pretend that the point spread
function is a delta
function in order
to get the geometrical
optics result. If it's not,
which is never the case, right?
Delta function is a
very good approximation.
So if it's not a delta
function, then the result
is not exactly like this,
but it is a convolution.
That is, basically this
will become blurry.
Like [? Pepe ?] showed earlier,
you will get a blurred vision--
or in general, an
especially filtered version
of the original
input will actually
survive through to the output.
What I would like
to point out now,
this is something that I
believe Se Baek also showed
last time, the same slide.
What I would like to
do is basically pay
a little bit of attention
to the scaling factors here.
These scaling factors are
actually very important.
So I mentioned that to drop
multiplicative factors that
appear in the front here.
This, it is OK to drop,
but these scaling factors
that go inside the
argument, these
are very important
because they determine
the amount of spatial filtering
that goes on inside the system.
So what I will do
actually for a while
is I will compare the 4F
system with a single lens
similar system.
So the scale factors,
again, they are different.
You see f1 is inside the
transfer function, and z1
in the case of the single lens.
So what is the
effect of that one?
Also in the incoherent case.
Of course, in the
incoherent case,
the transfer function
is the autocorrelation
of the coherent
transfer function,
and since the coherent
transfer function is basically
proportional to the
pupil mask, then what
we call the optical transfer
function, the incoherent case,
is an autocorrelation of
the pupil mask itself.
This is again a very basic
result, but again, be careful.
When we compute these
autocorrelations,
we have to apply
different scaling factors
in the argument.
OK.
So I will show in a second how
this works, and I will show it
in two cases.
One is what we called before
the Zernike phase mask.
Actually, this is
not exactly accurate.
Zernike did not
invent exactly this.
He invented another one
that has pi over 2 phase
shift at the edges.
It's like a ring.
But anyway, the
function is the same,
so everybody refers to all of
these types of masks as Zernike
nowadays.
So this is familiar.
We saw a few
examples in the past
when it was in the middle in the
focal plane of the 4F system,
and this is the case when
we put it as a pupil mask
in a single lens system.
It's the same mask.
It will do a very similar
thing, but there's
a subtle difference, so this
is what I want to point out.
So this is the
subtle difference.
What you see here is, of
course, the schematics,
so you see it is opaque
outside some amplitude.
Then inside, you have
this little extra phase
delay near the optical
access in a small region.
And OK, this is the
mathematical expression
that I don't want to dwell upon.
I'd rather focus on
these plots here.
So these two plots
are the magnitude
and the phase of the mask.
So the magnitude is the top.
The blue plot it
goes from 0 to 1.
So it is 1 within the amplitude,
so let's see if that's correct.
The amplitude has a
size of 1 centimeter,
so indeed this is 1
between minus 0.5 and 0.5.
And the phase, well, the phase,
nobody knows what the phase is.
Where the magnitude
is zero, we can not
define the phase for a complex
number that equals zero.
Nevertheless, let's
set it equal to zero.
But what I want to emphasize
is that within the past band
of the system, the phase is
0, except for a small chunk
of width of 0.2
centimeters where
the phase jumps to pi over 2.
Pi over 2 is of course i.
And this is the real
and imaginary part.
These two are
actually equivalent.
So the real part,
it is 1, except at
the little extra phase
protrusion there where
the real part goes to 0,
and the imaginary part
becomes 1 because of course
when the phase equals pi over 2,
then the actual complex
amplitude equals i.
So that's what you see here.
So these two pairs describe
both of the phase mask.
So the [INAUDIBLE] transfer
functions of course
are the same.
I only plotted them here as
a real and imaginary part,
but they have the same shape.
What is really different--
and unfortunately,
my plot is a little
bit too small here.
You cannot see very well--
is that they actually
have different sizes.
This one, if you do the scaling
factors here for the numbers
that I used, I think I used--
so I used lambda
equals 1 micron.
Lambda equals 1 micron,
f1 equals 10 centimeters,
f2 equals 1 centimeter
for the 4F system.
And then z1 equals
11 centimeters,
z2 equals 1.1 centimeters, and
f1 equals still 10 centimeters
for the single lens.
And I worked those out
so that in both cases,
you get the demagnification
of a factor of 10.
That's why the numbers are
a little bit strange there.
So in both cases, you get a
demagnification factor of 10,
and I did that deliberately
because the two systems give
you the same effect
kind of, but you
can see in terms of geometrical
optics, they are identical.
They both give you
a demagnification
by a factor of 10,
but you see here
that in terms of
wave optics, they're
slightly different
because one of them,
the 4F system is scaled
by the focal length.
Its spatial frequency
extends, goes
from minus 50 to 50
inverse millimeters.
This is what you see here.
Whereas in this case, it goes
from approximately minus 48
to 48 inverse millimeters.
So the single lens actually
does a slightly more severe
spatial filter than the
case of the 4F system.
That is to be expected, of
course, because the distance
z1--
you can see from here--
the distance z1 that you subtend
from the object to the aperture
is longer, so
therefore this system
is cutting off more
angles, or more spatial
frequencies than this system.
We will see that in
more detail in a second.
The other thing I want
to point out to you
is that if you take
that autocorrelation
of this function, which
is the coherent transfer
function or the ATF, if you
take its autocorrelation,
you obtain the OTF, which is, as
Se Baek demonstrated last time,
it is the transfer
function for spatially
incoherent illumination.
So again, this is a
little bit of an exercise
that I will not do here,
but it is in the notes.
I have posted another
set of practice problems.
So it is in pages 16
and 17 of the last set
of practice problems.
I have gone ahead
and derived this one,
and I would encourage
you to go through.
It's a little bit
of algebra, but you
can think of it as
mental fitness right
because you might say, why do
I need to do all this algebra?
When would I ever have
to do so much algebra?
I can just plug it into
Matlab, and I get it.
Well, I'm sure all of you
do some kind of fitness.
You go to the gym, right?
When you do bench presses,
what is the probability
that you need to do a bench
press motion in real life?
It's actually very small.
So you do bench presses
in order to keep fit.
So the reason we do these
kind of calculations
is it's the equivalent of
mental bench presses, right,
so I would encourage
you to do it.
Because presumably you are
at MIT because you have you
want to have mental fitness
as well as physical fitness.
Let me talk a little bit more
about these scaling factors.
So in this case, this is just a
clear aperture that I put here,
and you can see that in the
case of the clear aperture,
it's actually very easy to
do sort of the ray diagrams,
and you can see also here that--
well, let me back
up for a second.
So you remember from
geometrical optics,
we had the definition of
the numerical aperture.
So we defined the numerical
aperture as the angle
that we subtend towards
the optical system
if we place a point
source on axis.
So therefore, the
numerical aperture
is limited by one of the
physical apertures that
are in the system.
So in the case of the 4F system,
that would be the pupil mask.
At some point in
any physical system,
the pupil mask
cannot be infinite.
It has to be finite, so the
physical diameter of the pupil
mask, assuming the lenses
themselves are large enough,
the pupil mask will become
the limiting factor.
And so we can compute the
numerical aperture then.
It is the ratio of
the radius of the mask
over the focal length, f1.
You can see it very easily
from this triangle over here.
And of course this is an
approximate expression.
In reality, the
numerical apertures
would be the sine over
the inverse tangent
of this quantity,
but of course we're
doing [INAUDIBLE]
approximations here,
so we can drop the
trigonometric functions.
In the case of the single lens
the numerical aperture is--
again, you can get it from
this triangle over here,
but now the one of the
orthogonal sides is z1, not f1.
So you can see that the
numerical aperture is
r over z1, and of course if this
system is supposed to produce
a real image, as opposed
to a virtual image,
then z1 must be longer than f1.
You can see very clearly
from the imaging condition,
1 over z1 plus 1 over
z2 equals 1 over f.
If you want z2 to be positive--
so for z2 to be positive, it
means I have a real image--
for this, it is required
that z1 is bigger than f.
So because of that, you can see
that if you have the same size
pupil mask, the single lens
system would have a smaller
numerical aperture.
That is sort of an
unfortunate fact of life.
So another thing I
want to point out here
is that the numerical
aperture actually
changes when you go to the
second leg of the system
because, of course, the system
has angular magnification.
So what started as a numerical
aperture at the input
is of course an angle.
If you take the
marginal ray, it is
propagating at a given
angle with respect
to the optical axis.
By the time it comes out,
this angle will have changed.
By how much?
By the angular
magnification of the system.
So therefore, the numerical
aperture at the output
is not the same.
It equals the numerical aperture
at the input times the angular
magnification of the system.
So this is not a
cause for confusion.
We can use either one.
We'll get actually the
same conclusions whether we
use the numerical
aperture or the input
or the numerical
aperture at the output,
but we have to be a
little bit careful
that we don't confuse
things, as long
as we remember this
simple relationship
that the two are connected
by the angular magnification.
So the reason the numerical
aperture is so important is
because if you consider
a circular-- of course,
you cannot see the circle here.
This is just the projection.
But imagine that I
have a circular pupil.
Then recall that the point
spread function of the system
is actually the
Fourier transform
of that circular pupil because
this is a clear aperture now.
And we learned sometime ago--
I don't remember when--
but we learned that
the Fourier transform
of a circular function
is this crazy [? zinc ?]
so-called function that is given
by a ratio of a Bessel function
to its argument, and
it's probably better
to think of it as a
plot like this one that
has a main lobe and then
a smaller side lobe.
And actually, it
has a lot of lobes.
It continues on forever, but the
size of the lobes decays away.
How fast it decays away
is 1 over the argument.
So what I want to point out
here is that in both cases,
the point spread the
function of the system
looks like this
[? zinc ?] functions.
Sometimes it's also
known as an Airy disk.
Not an Airy
function, by the way.
Airy function is different.
This one is referred
to as Airy disk.
If you're curious
what Airy function, is
you can open the
table of formulas.
Abramowitz and [INAUDIBLE],, and
you'll see a monstrous thing.
That's called the Airy
function, and this turns out
to be a special case
of an Airy function.
But anyway, this
is the Airy disk,
and what I want to emphasize
is that in both cases,
you get the same shape of Airy
disk, but different in size.
And you'll get different size
because in the case of the 4F
system, the size of the
aperture is the same,
but because the scaling
factor is smaller--
it is f1-- then you
actually get a bigger ATF.
The size of the disk in the
frequency domain is bigger.
Therefore, it will give you a
slightly narrower point spread
function.
If you work out these
ratios over here,
and you work out
these coefficients,
you will see that
very clearly, but I
want you to get it
sort of intuitively
by using the scaling theorem
of Fourier transform.
In both cases, you start with
the same physical aperture,
but what matters is not the
physical size of the aperture,
but the numerical aperture.
So in one case, you have
this numerical aperture.
This is a f1.
This is the physical size,
and numerical aperture
is R over f1.
In the other case, you have
again the same aperture,
but now you have a
longer distance here.
This is still R. So now
the numerical aperture
would be R over z1.
So the same physical
aperture in the two cases
will actually give you a
different size in the ATF.
This will have a bigger ATF.
So the size of the ATF,
if you work it out,
it will be proportional to
actually 1 over lambda f1,
and the size of the ATF here--
I'm exaggerating, of course--
will be proportional
to 1 over lambda z1.
OK, so since we've got the
smaller size of the ATF
in this case, it means that
we'll get a broader PSF.
So which system is better?
Well, obviously this
one because this one
will give you a narrower PSF.
Therefore, it will give
you a smaller blur.
So of course there's a caveat.
I sort of took it for
granted that the desirable
in an optical system is to
minimize the blur, which
in most cases it's true.
If for some reason someone
asked you deliberately
to produce a system that
causes a lot of blur,
then of course you would go for
this one, but in most cases,
we try to minimize blur.
So this means, given
our resources--
that is, given our physical
size of the numerical aperture--
we should try to maximize
the numerical aperture,
and that is what the
photo system is doing.
So there are a few comments
about the resolution that
are in the rest of the slides.
I don't want to destroy
the rest of your morning.
Because the PSF
is finite, you can
imagine that if
you have two point
sources that are at distance.
So now this is
like an experiment.
I'm moving two point
sources together.
There will come a point
where the two point
sources will merge.
And if this is
your image now, you
don't really know whether you
had one point source or two.
Now, of course you
say, well, you also
get twice the intensity.
That's true, but very
often you don't know
the intensity you started with.
For example, if you're
looking at the sky,
and you're looking
at the bright dot
and you're trying to decide,
is it one star or two stars?
Well, so far we cannot yet
go to the stars and measure
their brightness, right?
We can only measure
the total brightness
that we receive here.
So therefore, if you're
looking at a telescope,
and you see this, you
don't know if there's
one star or two stars that
are too close to be resolved
by your telescope.
So actually, this
sort of situation
was dealt with by a fellow
called Rayleigh, and of course,
the size of the
PSF, as I worked out
before, it depends on
the numerical aperture.
So I will go over
this in more detail
later, but this
is just a preview
that the numerical aperture
actually gives you an idea--
I actually believe also
Professor [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned it in one
of the past lectures.
The numerical aperture
gives you an idea
about the capability of your
system to resolve point images.
So imagine that each
one of these lobes
here corresponds to the point
spread function of one point
object.
So in this case, they were
resolved because I spaced them
so that the diameter
of the main lobe
falls exactly on one
null of the other lobe.
So if you work it out,
and you take into care
into where the zeros
of the Bessel function
are located and
so on, you come up
with an expression
that looks like this.
The space in between
the two sources
is 1.22 times the
wavelength divided
by the numerical aperture.
And of course this would
be at the input plane.
So this would be the spacing
at the input required
so that the two sources
can be resolved.
But when you look at the
output, the distance of course
would be given by a
similar expression,
but the numerical
aperture at the output
would appear in this case.
And of course this is sort of
the most common definition.
Some books define
the resolution--
instead of the diameter,
they use the radius,
so they come up with an
expression that is exactly 1/2.
Which one is
correct, it actually
depends on your requirements.
If you require a
very crisp image,
or if you're dealing with
a very noisy situation,
then you go for this
one because as you
can imagine if you organize
noise into this one,
then it becomes
progressively more
difficult to resolve
the two spots.
So in a very noisy
environment, when
you have a very
little light, then
you go for this definition.
If you have plenty
of light, then you
can possibly resolve two sources
that are very close like this,
right.
Here you see you have
very poor contrast.
You basically have to rely--
in order to resolve
the two sources,
you have to rely on this
little dip in density.
So if your signal is
noisy, this may be lost,
and then you cannot
resolve anymore.
OK, so that's a
preview of resolution.
We'll talk about this
a little bit more.